Samantha Gary has been friends with
Christine Blasi Ford for 40 years and
they went to high school together we
spoke to her earlier from a studio
across town here in Washington Samantha
she is said in her statement today that
she is terrified about testing
testifying but as you point out she says
it's her civic duty she also said that
she was afraid and ashamed to talk to
anybody about this this incident so how
is she preparing for today what is she
doing well you know she's been largely
sequestered she's a very private person
anyway and having this very bright light
shone on her in this instance has been
daunting so she's spent quite a bit of
time on her own
quietly gathering her thoughts gathering
her strength so that she is prepared
some of the questions today will be very
personal as you know about her marriage
her mental health her politics do you
think that she is ready for that kind of
scrutiny in such a public setting are
you worried about her I am definitely
worried about her I would be you know
who wouldn't be scared to get up and
have to talk about these incredibly
private things in such a incredibly
public way to strangers who have already
many of whom already said that that her
testimony doesn't really matter to them
so that's that's frightening but she's
fierce and she's smart and she's sincere
and she will no one should underestimate
her she's gonna do great today
Samantha some of the questioning about
her recollection of this event is
centered around the specificity on the
one hand but also the vagueness on on
the other hand in terms of her account
how do you sort through those details is
it possible in your mind while you
believe your friend and you believe that
something happened are you as certain
that it was this specific person judge
Kavanagh that was involved in whatever
happened
I am I am I I think it's well-documented
from everything I've been hearing as
well as through the news or whatnot that
in people who have had these types of
traumas have acute memory of a lot of
details and then there are a lot of
things that are somewhat vague so I
think that's fairly typical but in this
case she knew Brett Kavanaugh she knew
exactly who was attacking her and
there's no question about his identity
this is something that she's been clear
on from the beginning and in every
instance that she's brought this
information forward to a friend she has
been clear about that okay Samantha Gary
we're even have to leave it there thanks
so much my pleasure